I'm Gregg Jarrett I'm Sandra Smith I'm
Charles Payne and this is the Fox News
rundown
[Music]
Wednesday March 25th 2020 and Lisa Brady
even during a global pandemic riding to
America's rescue is no easy feat in
Washington we really are in this
terrible US versus in that moment where
where any advantage you can have over
your political opponent must be taken
even in the worst of times I'm Dave
Anthony for many Americans the bills are
piling up but the paychecks aren't
coming anymore I'm encouraging people to
really get into conserve mode right now
and buy conserve mode what I mean is as
all unnecessary spending must stop
immediately and I'm Cal Thomas I've got
the final word on the Fox News rundown
[Music]
while millions of Americans are
essentially hibernating to help stop the
spread of the new coronavirus a new
spirit of cooperation has been sprouting
in Washington but that didn't last long
I don't know what's in the hearts but
we've seen this before where they
clearly have shown they'd rather hurt
the country for their own political
power and it is just disgusting Arizona
senator martha mcsalley among the
republicans blaming democrats after
phase three of coronavirus relief an
epic stimulus package stalled following
days of bipartisan talks between
lawmakers and the White House Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
questioning Republican priorities and
we're fighting for transparency
oversight disclosure when the federal
government gives corporations money hope
for an eventual consensus was enough to
help fuel a record rally on Wall Street
Tuesday but how does the politics of
this look from the outside it's a call
to stop and think before you react
congressman Dan Crenshaw is Republican
congressman from Texas and a former Navy
SEAL in an op-ed on foxnews.com he rips
into China for its initial handling of
early reports about the virus and
subsequent propaganda criticizing the
u.s. Crenshaw calls it another chapter
in misinformation campaigns that
manipulate America's freedoms and
divisions to benefit our enemies you
know we have to be stronger as a country
and a part of being mentally tough is
the ability to stop before you tweet
stop before you or you say stuff before
you say that thing on Facebook before
you share that that that piece of
unverified information you know I always
question like do people really think
that calling it the Chinese virus is
racist you know I loved the people
saying that the people that the people
perpetuating that narrative I wonder I
wonder if they would pass a lie-detector
test I don't in my my my intuition is
that they wouldn't my intuitions is they
don't actually believe that their fellow
Americans are racist I don't think they
actually
leave that but they're willing to say it
and they're willing to say it loudly and
you know why is that well it's political
opportunities are more than anything
else right because we really are in this
terrible us-versus-them moment where
we're any advantage you can have over
your political opponent must be taken
even in the worst of times and I think I
think that's the the the message I'm
trying to send people I mean just to
stop and think and and again political
opportunities there were more examples
of that well the this past week has been
that when the Democrats torpedoed a it
was a bipartisan rescue package for the
American economy the only reason is
political opportunism I mean there's
there's it's a real shame and this just
isn't the time for it all the times this
just isn't the time for it to counter
the Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
has said look they just want more focus
on workers and small businesses they're
worried about corporations having too
much leeway with billions of dollars in
taxpayer funding we cannot have a
situation where when a company is
getting money from the Treasury Federal
Reserve that they we don't know about it
I mean is any of that a legitimate
argument no it's not and they know it
here's the other thing Chuck Schumer was
talking about how bipartisan the package
was on Saturday so what made him change
his tune he knew it was in the package
he was happy with it before why would
all of a sudden his his mind change well
because Nancy Pelosi who is it was it
was extremely influenced by the far-left
got into the negotiating room and
changed everything on them and so let's
address let's address each of those
concerns around rather quickly so first
of all bigger picture what is the goal
of an economic rescue package the goal
of an economic rescue package is is to
keep fuel in the economy as we press
pause on it okay so we deliberately said
to businesses you can no longer operate
we deliberately said stop going into
businesses we deliberately said you
can't take any more revenue if you're
going to do that you have to inject
capital into those businesses and and
make sure that they can keep people on
payroll I am not sure how to be more Pro
worker than to keep
people working keep people getting their
paycheck Democrats have this odd sense
of wonder how in economy functions they
think that the government can just keep
giving people money and let them get
laid off there's nothing for a worker
about that and and as much as they hate
this notion that corporations employ
people they do they employ Americans and
again what I like to point out is an
American that loses their job whether
they work for a small company or a big
company it is no different it's still in
America still your neighbor and as far
as a there not being any protections for
workers I mean in fact there was quite a
bit of regulation put into that
bipartisan bill for instance in there if
you're gonna take these direct lending
programs you couldn't do stock buybacks
can't increase pay for executives they
capped pay for executives also said that
had to have the payroll the same payroll
since March 13th so again it's quite
literally protecting workers jobs you
can't be a worker if you're not working
okay then you're just unemployed and
into de-facto employ government employee
because you're just hoping that the
government will give you money but
that's not we what we want to do we want
to press pause on the economy while we
do well we deliberately slow the spread
of the virus and and allow people to
restart the economy rather quickly once
we've gotten the public health side
figured out what is your home state of
Texas doing to help small businesses you
have any sense of how you know the
average Texan is handling this economic
shutdown in general well they're hurting
I mean hurting badly a friend of Mines
restaurant and barbecue joint just
closed I was just visiting another
restaurant might in my district and
they're they're on the brink of closing
they've lost a ton of their business but
here's what they need most they need
some predictability and this is what I'm
encouraging Texas leaders to do and
encourage the President to back up which
I think he is we need a timeline okay we
need balance between the public health
side and the economy side there's two
crises going on right now
it's the pandemic and it's the economy
and we need to have balance between
those two and eventually we need to be
have a very clear timeline where we
transition to a more targeted
what someone call a vertical approach is
opposed to a horizontal approach because
right now we've shut down horizontally
the entire economy eventually we need to
be we needed to be more targeted and how
we deal with this you know making sure
that we're taking care of our most
vulnerable population making sure that
we're so encouraging social distancing
but also getting back to work especially
for those who are less vulnerable those
without getting pre-existing conditions
younger population and you know people
like myself and many others like me so
this is the balance that I think we need
to strike and the economy needs a
predictable timeline in order to do that
I think that would help a lot one of the
things that I also hear happening it
seems like on a daily basis is this kind
of tug-of-war of information between
what the federal government says and
what some states say and I raise this
because the New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo in particular keeps saying you
want a pat on the back for sending 400
ventilators what are we gonna do for 400
with 400 ventilators when we need 30,000
ventilators and he kind of issued a
warning on Tuesday we are just the test
case and that's how the nation should
look at it look at us today
where we are today you will be in three
weeks or four weeks or five weeks or six
weeks we are your future what is the
American people supposed to do when they
hear these kind of conflicting
narratives the states saying one thing
and the federal government saying oh but
we are stepping up and trying to help
you is it just a case of time where it
takes a long time for the federal
initiatives to kind of filter through
yeah I'm not sure that example is a
conflict and narrative necessarily if
Governor Cuomo says he needs more
ventilators I believe him
that the federal government says they're
going to try and get him more
ventilators I believe them is it going
to move as fast as we want to
it never is going to move as fast as we
want to we need to try and make it as
move move as fast as possible you know
but this is an example of in a broader
in a broader sense maybe the the
conflict is why are some states
implementing more draconian measures in
some states aren't I think the answer to
that is well some states like New York
simply have more cases they're there
they're working off of the reality that
they live in this is why we have a
federalist structure what makes sense
for New York doesn't necessarily make
sense for Ohio with less cases or even
Texas with a lot less cases so I'm not
sure there's a conflict as I understand
it Governor Cuomo and the president were
working quite well together you have an
extremely what sounds now like a very
timely book coming out on April of 7th
fortitude American resilience in the era
of outrage
yeah and I'm excited about it of course
it's probably the worst time to actually
come out with a book but I can't control
that well a lot of people need new stuff
to read so I don't know maybe it's a
good time every chapter in that book is
a lesson in mental toughness and the
premise of the book is outraged culture
this this tendency that we have and it's
gotten way worse over the last decade to
find the worst in each other to use
social media to cancel people and call
for their firing and and really just
take the most aggressive stance possible
even when it's unnecessary but that's
the
and you know what I argue is that that
outraged culture that victimhood culture
it's really transformed into this sort
of hatred of our institutions of each
other this group on group identity
politics and ultimately this this
tearing down of the story of America and
the story of America's Founding and and
I bring up a lot of examples and that
throughout it but but mostly it's a it's
mostly it's not a political book it's
actually very very light on the politics
and I'm I'm very careful to criticize
conservatives as well as liberals in it
but mostly it's a personal fortitude
book okay so so every lesson is derived
from my experience in combat and the
SEAL Teams it's derived from history
it's derived from psychology and so we
really dive deep into the psychology
behind suffering and and how that's
beneficial to your daily life sounds
like good inspiration Texas congressman
Dan Crenshaw former Navy SEAL and now
author as well thanks a lot for your
time
great to be with you thanks for having
me
[Music]
this is Cal Thomas with your FoxNews
commentary coming up this coronavirus
outbreak is not slowing down in the u.s.
yet but President Trump is just about
had it with what it's doing to the
economy people are gonna go at a
business and they're gonna go bankrupt
and they're not gonna have jobs what are
we talking about here the president
reiterating when he first tweeted early
Monday that the cure of shutting down
businesses restricting gatherings
keeping people at home can't be worse
than the problem I would love to have
the country opened up and just raring to
go by Easter he said that to Bill Hemmer
during a fox news town hall forum on
Tuesday that's 19 days from now okay is
that true is that possible or is
anything's possible why isn't it I mean
we've never closed the country before
we've had some pretty bad flus and we've
had some pretty bad viruses and I think
it's absolutely possible now people are
going to have to practice all of the
social distancing and don't shake hands
and wash your hands and all of the
things that we're doing now but we have
to get our country back to work a lot of
Americans have already taken a financial
hit and it's expected to get worse this
is a tough time times like we've not
seen before on a global scale Chris
Hogan is a personal finance expert you
know the reality is is with seventy
seventy nine percent of Americans live
in paycheck to paycheck and millions of
people that are dealing with income or
job loss by the end of this month this
is tough and so you know the first thing
I want to tell people to do is just take
a collective deep breath and let's
really start to really focus on the
things that we can control and I tell
people that as a start point because I
think it's so necessary there's so many
things we can't control we cannot
control Congress we cannot control this
virus right now and all the uncertainty
that's going on but we can't control our
attitude our outlook and our actions and
staying in control of those three things
I'm honing in on the action part of
things on the finances where I'm
encouraging people to really get into
conserve mode right now right and buy
conserve mode what I mean is there's all
unnecessary spending
stop immediately and I'm talking about
the gym memberships because you're
you're still paying for those online
even though the gym is closed or any
unnecessary subscription so that
conserve mode is the first weight first
place to start because Dave I'm telling
people you have to take care of the four
walls and what I mean by four walls this
would be your your housing as well as
your utilities your food your
transportation and having clothes on
your back all right now what do people
do you said that about four and five of
us live paycheck to paycheck so that
means there's really not much emergency
funding for a lot of people not a lot of
money in the bank so do we prioritize
what bills we have to pay obviously food
you can't go without that we're gonna
eat the food that we have in our
pantries the stuff that we have in our
freezer and so you know we're gonna have
some creative meals right now but the
most important thing is to have
substance and to make sure that you're
able to take care of your family all
right
with April first looming let's deal with
rent and let's deal with mortgage
because obviously everyone's different
what can people do they're not getting
paid they have a bill what should they
do what's the next step well I think
first and foremost of the first steps
you can take is to acknowledge that this
is tough and it's frustrating but we're
going to take action and as I tell
people even if you don't have money to
pay you can pay attention to the bill
and that means picking up the phone and
contacting the creditor so you're
calling your landlord you're obviously
talking about the job law so the income
loss and all the things that are going
on and you're beginning to have a
discussion on what you can afford to do
and win and this is not something that
is an easy conversation as I tell people
you're not debating you're stating and
that means you're being clear about what
you can afford to do and upfront and
honest and so you've got to have that
discussion and the same would be said
with rent as well as with a mortgage
you're gonna contact your mortgage
servicer explain to them the situation
take notes on who you spoke with ask
them to document your account so as
other people start to call they can at
least have a background of your
situation and what
going on so could you say make a deal
with them and say what if I pay interest
only can you do things like that well
some with a you know everybody is going
to be different
and typically with secured debts Dave
and by secured debts I'm talking about
car loans motorcycle loans and mortgages
where it's secured by real collateral
most of the time they will not accept a
partial payment so they don't have to so
you can contact them and have a
conversation to find out what they're
willing to do some places are discussing
about pushing the payments until the end
so it would just extend the period of
indebtedness just because that's being
discussed doesn't mean that necessarily
your lender or mortgage provider has
agreed to that so I think it's always
good to be proactive contact them take
notes of who you spoke with the date and
the time and keep that for your records
okay so let's say you have a loan and a
payments do you could talk to them and
they would say okay you don't pay us in
April that payment will be tacked on to
the end of the term of your loan
next payments due in May is that is that
what you're talking about that is
absolutely correct and that is something
that they do have the capacity to do if
we think back to the whole real estate
and mortgage issue we had in Oh 708 no.9
mortgage companies were doing that for
people but again it required us to reach
out to contact the lender and to talk
about our situation all right now let's
move to dealing with the other expenses
that you might have other things in your
like credit cards for instance away from
loans people have a lot of credit card
debt what do you just make the minimum
payment I know your personal finance
guys hate having debt but at the moment
is that what you do just pay the minimum
and just move on it really is especially
with an unsecured debt so credit card
loans personal loans things of that
nature you're going to just pay the
minimum and you know I want people to
attack that but right now we're in
conserve mode so you're gonna pay the
minimum you're gonna save the other
amount for now until we get clarity
around this virus and get it contained
and with an unsecured debt if you don't
have the money and you've got five or
six credit cards typical credit card
hovering around 12,000 right now per
household but if you don't have the
money for the minimum we're gonna do the
same thing we did with a mortgage
company we're gonna call but this time
we're gonna be a little bit more firm
because with non secured debt like
credit cards and personal loans there's
nothing they can come take with your
home you can lose your home you can lose
where you're living with a credit card
it's rare for them to come pursue you
legally they can but again if we're
communicating and being upfront and
asking them to document the account and
you're communicating clearly sending
them something your minimum payment may
be $50 and if all you can afford to send
them as 10 they something is better than
nothing
all right student loans what about those
student loans are tough and you know
right now I would contact them and have
the same kind of conversation that I
would have with a mortgage talking to
them about paying interest or paying
something and working with them again
for people that are out there dealing
with this crunch this is they aren't the
only people dealing with this millions
of people are walking through this kind
of scenario and dealing with it and so
again with some of the student loans
they have waived payments but again you
need to call to find out if your student
loan provider is one of those it is
expected that unemployment is gonna
spike there are predictions of a jobless
rate that could hit twenty maybe thirty
percent
small businesses employ a majority of
Americans and the US Chamber of Commerce
survey estimates a third of companies
with fewer than 500 employees have no
funds for unexpected losses
so yes cutting payroll and laying people
off is happening so how should small
businesses be handling things well again
it's gonna come back to really taking a
collective deep breath my heart goes out
to these small businesses I'm a former
small business owner myself the
entrepreneurs that know entrepreneurs
out there that had this vision of
serving people and bringing a product or
service to the market right now they
have to go in to conserve and protect
mode as well there's a lot of
discussions about programs the Small
Business Administration providing things
these funds to these small businesses
again right now it is conjecture and
just talk what these small business
owners need to do is to go in to protect
mode for
selves as I tell them I want them to get
on a budget immediately I want them to
take care of the four walls
that's the housing and utilities their
food transportation and clothing they
need to pause any kind of extra payments
toward debt and make minimum payments
they need to sell some stuff they may
have some inventory a friend of mine
owns a steak house and right now what
he's doing is he can't have people come
in to eat so when he's doing this
selling some of the inventory some of
the steaks wholesale out to some of his
customers and so again being able to
pivot and think differently and respond
to this situation by being proactive are
they the ones even more so than
individual Americans that are sitting
there waiting for Congress for loans for
whatever it is that they can do well I
think you know unfortunately a lot of
people are pinning their hopes on what
Congress may or may not do and so I want
people to adapt the mentality of being
able to help themselves by being
proactive looking to take on a temporary
job or a side job let's get in the
mindset of protecting ourselves even if
they do decide on the stimulus package
which I hope they do and they send out a
check again this could be a one-time
check it doesn't mean that it's going to
be ongoing so it's time for us to adapt
and overcome in this situation life has
changed as normal and so when we pivot
and we make necessary changes we can
respond accordingly and to be able to
have a game plan moving forward
unfortunately in this epidemic this
pandemic people are dying
more people will or get really sick is
everybody behind on this do you think
being ready if there's an emergency to
have someone else in the household take
over managing the money well I think a
lot of people are and you know
unfortunately no one can predict things
like this and so you know the mindset
around this is going to be a wake-up
call for a lot of people being able to
be prepared and to be able to respond if
you have elderly parents
you know it's very important to get a
power of attorney in place so you're
able to pay bills on their behalf if
you're not on
checking account you're not allowed to
have access by the banks laws and so a
power of attorney is going to be
something very important to have as well
as having a will this is just having our
wishes in order seventy-five percent of
Americans do not have a will which means
that the government would make decisions
about your stuff and so I think this is
going to be a wake-up call for a lot of
people with their finances but also with
their estates just beginning to look at
this and having some things in place a
plan can give you a peace of mind when
you're clear on that plan and everyone's
on the same page what about someone who
is single with kids and all these bills
what do they do to be prepared for
someone to manage their money if they
get sick forget their parents what a
thing it's sick
well and it's very important you know
even if you're single with children to
make sure that you've got an executor
and someone that that is you is going to
take care of your kids and your estate
and so it's really important to talk to
the you know have that friend that you
really trust or that family member that
you trust and talk with them ask them to
if they're willing to be that executor
and then you could this is things that
you can put together inside of a
state-specific will these are not
extremely expensive you can do it online
for a couple of hundred dollars or you
can go sit down with an attorney but if
you have young people that you're
responsible for it is imperative to not
only have a will in place but to also
have term life insurance I tell people
you want to have 10 to 12 times your
annual income in term life insurance and
Dave it's really important not to have
this insurance inside of your job you
need to have an outside of your job so
if you are laid off or you lose your job
you don't lose your life insurance
lastly how much cash should I have
squirreled away in case whatever happens
to my bank account or whatever well I
think it's it's important for us to
understand that unlike the situation
that we dealt with in oh seven and oh
eight where we had a banking and real
estate crisis this is not a banking
crisis right now what we have is a virus
we have a pandemic going on with an
invisible enemy and so the banks are
okay you know the FDIC ensures every
account up to two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars so if you want to have
some cash at home at
but make sure you have a fireproof safe
your money is best is more safe in a
bank than it is in your home well we all
hope our money is safe in this but it's
it's a real tough time Chris Hogan
thanks so much for joining us thank you
for having me sir
[Music]
the download and make it hammer time
with Bill Hemmer trey gowdy welcome so
if the department is gonna start issuing
making public investigations about
people that you don't even have enough
information to charge that is a slippery
slope
subscribe and listen now by going to Fox
News podcasts dot-com rate and review
the Fox News rundown on Apple podcasts
or wherever you listen it's time for
your fox news commentary what's on your
mind
if anything good can come from the
corona virus pandemic it's the
revelation of America's over-reliance on
China especially when it comes to drugs
interviewed by NBC News retired
Brigadier General John Adams said quote
basically we've outsourced our entire
industry to China that is a strategic
vulnerability unquote Adams spent his
30-year military career as an
intelligence officer a military attache
in South Korea and Deputy US military
representative to NATO he told the
network he thinks China knows quote
exactly what they're doing
and they're incredibly good strategists
they select their industries for the
future and they've got a plan unquote
China has threatened to restrict drug
exports to the US following president
Trump's accusation that the regime
withheld news of the virus which
surfaced in Wuhan last December the New
York Times reports Chinese
pharmaceutical companies have supplied
more than 90 percent of US antibiotics
vitamin C ibuprofen and hydrocortisone
as well as 70 percent of acetaminophen
and 40 to 45 percent of heparin in
recent years according to yang Seong
Wong a senior fellow for global health
at the Council on Foreign Relations
that's called leverage and Beijing could
use it anytime it chooses it has
recently threatened to do so I once
tried buying American focusing on items
made only in this country I gave up
after a few days it was nearly
impossible to find anything not stamped
made in China for too long US businesses
have outsourced to China exploiting
their cheap labor to maximize profits
while supply chains are more diversified
than ever it would be a patriotic
exercise and in our best interests if we
could slowly transition
many goods and services back to America
nightly Business Report reported last
summer what should become a trend quote
the pace of companies moving production
out of China is accelerating as more
than 50 multinationals from Apple to
Nintendo to Dell are rushing to escape
the punitive tariffs placed by the US
according to the Nikkei Asian review if
President Trump could promise to bring
back jobs from overseas as he did and
has why couldn't he do the same with
drugs and other essentials made in China
it could not happen all at once any more
than the outsourcing occurred overnight
but we could begin the process and this
virus that has infected and affected the
world gives our leaders an opportunity
to start many of the profits earned by
China from US businesses have gone to
support its vast military and expand its
reach in other parts of the world in a
story about China's growing presence in
Latin America Business Insider noted
quote in early December El Salvador's
president announced that China had
agreed to gigantic non-refundable
cooperation with his country investing
an undisclosed amount in projects
including a stadium water treatment
plant and tourist development less than
two weeks later Argentina's new
government said it was ready to join the
belt and road initiative China's
sprawling infrastructure and development
effort which would make it the first of
the region's four major economies to do
so those two developments at opposite
ends of Latin America are only the
latest science of China's deepening ties
in the region the u.s. views China's
rapid expansion warily but seems unsure
of what to do about it
China poses a greater threat to US
interests than the Sandinistas and other
communist and communist back groups ever
did we'd better pay attention to China's
plans and take countermeasures or made
in China could eventually be stamped on
the United States I'm Cal Thomas
you have been listening to the FoxNews
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
the Fox News radios hourly newscast at
Fox News podcasts dot-com and for
up-to-the-minute news visit Fox news.com
download fox news channels the five
podcast for free five of your favorite
fox news personalities discussed current
issues in a roundtable discussion get it
now on Apple podcasts Google Play in Fox
News podcasts dot-com love Fox News
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust and
click the FoxNews rundown playlist for
the latest episodes